[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in charles barkley tnt
inside the nba
analyst and uh last time i talked to you
about this topic with james harden
that was november 25th and you didn't
think it could work
change your opinion not at all
i don't think it's gonna work uh i think
it's gonna be
uh i thought they bought him in because
they wasn't sure what was gonna happen
with kyrie it brought him in that's the
insurance policy uh and now i think it's
going to be
fascinating watching those three guys
play together if they
all play together i mean we have no idea
what's going on with kyrie uh but
no i don't think it's gonna work at all
but those other guys don't bring in the
diversity
to to the table uh those other two guys
they are offensive
players they don't play defense they
don't rebound
so there's only one basketball i i think
it's got zero chance of working
but you also and you know this where it
feels like kd could get 30
on 16 shots you know he he would find a
way get to the line and he can be
economical the other guys are volume
shooters certainly harden is
and then i just wonder what kind of
offense do you run
when you have three alphas like that
well i think that's why i don't think
it's gonna work i think it's really
gonna be like they're just gonna take
turns and i don't think that's gonna
work because like i say other than kd
the other two guys
they're not gonna like when katie went
to golden state he's like okay i'll play
defense and i'll rebound the ball
i don't see kyrie and james doing that i
think when kd got the ball they're just
going to be standing around
uh and so i don't think like i say
listen i don't think it's going to work
at all
it's going to be fun watching uh because
how one seeing how james and kyrie
handle the new york media to me is going
to be like the most fascinating part of
this whole thing
but if the if we know this the nets have
to know this then how is this going to
work
so what are they thinking that why is
this going to work in their minds
and we have you know a big question mark
attached to it
well cause i think it's what kd wanted
to do i mean kd wanted kyrie and now i
think he realized it now like
yeah this is not going to work i better
bring james in here as an insurance
policy
that that's what i think happened but
clearly kd is running the organization
uh so i think this was about what he
wanted
what do you think steve nash is thinking
today
i'm gonna get the blame if this thing
don't work
they're gonna kill me like you know and
i really think they put steve in a
really awkward position christine ash is
a health officer was a great player and
he's a great guy
but you you got you got one guy comes
out
and says hey we don't need a coach
and now you bring in james who clearly
shows up when he wants to
uh so i think it really puts steve
between a rock and a hard place
because listen if they have to get rid
of somebody
it's gonna be steve nash but it's not
gonna be
james um james or
kd but you know i think but i think
kyrie is the wild card
in this whole thing to be honest with
you yeah that's what i was going to
bring up
do you think that they're ready to move
on from kyrie
because i don't know what everybody's
kind of casual about where kyrie is and
what he's doing
i don't know if he wants to play and it
doesn't sound like he's
really that interested in coming back
anytime soon well i think this is the
reason they made the trade
i think the the nets have lost faith in
kyrie they're like
and and i actually i think kevin has a
lot like nah i better bring james in
here
because listen even without kyrie
james and k.d together is pretty
formidable
i mean they're going to be just as good
uh with or without kyrie
so i think kd's like yo man i can't
trust this
dude he shows up when he wants to he's
going to do his
own thing i've got to bring james in as
an instrument
hey listen let's be something something
straight this is probably the greatest
insurance policy we have a seat in the
nba
how do you feel if you're ben simmons
today
well i think he can relax now and
realize that the sixers
this is his team and joelle's team
we got no idea who the best team in the
eastern conference is
and uh he's got to let you see ben and
joelle got to come to the understanding
that
hey you know what we ran our other coach
out of town he took the he took the
sword sword for us
now we got doc it's time for us to start
doing our job we're in our prime
right now so i think him and joelle got
to take a look in the mirror and say hey
listen
we let them blame brett brown whether it
was true or not we let them blame him
but now we got doc we've got to get our
stuff together
you think lebron and a.d are concerned
about what the nets just did
no i mean they're still the best uh duo
listen there's nobody
right now if you get any fool or jackass
on your show today
we're all guessing about the nets
ain't nobody gonna get on here and tell
you
they are the nba favors right now if
they do that they don't know
anything about basketball i mean we got
i got to be honest with you dan i said
this when you said this a few months ago
i would love to be a fly on the wall now
because i pray
that they got james harden because i
want to see this social experiment
and it's going to be fun it's going to
be fascinating
and it's in new york city
do you think the commissioner likes this
deal
no i think that he don't uh at first
well adam's amazing but i don't think he
wants players running the league
uh because because because listen let's
get one thing the commissioner always
works for the owners
so i don't think i mean there's only
like three or four
players who have this type of power but
what they don't understand is when you
lose your superstars you ruin franchises
there used to be a great you know people
said well some the team
won the championship yeah but there were
still great players
in other cities and now we're making so
many cities irrelevant
and listen let's i know one thing i
cannot wait for this the collective
bargaining agreement when he's on to
slap these boys back
it's going to be very fascinating
because everybody's like well the
players got all this power
yeah but they don't have all that money
and the
four or five players who are great
they're gonna get
all that they they gonna get all their
money but these guys
underneath they're gonna be hurting in a
few years
what do you think lebron would be worth
if there was no salary cap
well i've always thought that was a
stupid argument
uh dan everybody's making money
listen if we just gonna pay the
superstars we'd only be paying like
three
three or four players and everybody else
be making a million dollars
let's say hypothetically lebron was
worth 670 million
they're not gonna pay everybody else at
least now
we got five think about it
there's three guys on the nets gonna be
making 40 million dollars
and probably only one of them deserve to
be making 40 million dollars
and think about it there's a bunch of
guys on the lakers who make
six to 10 to 15 million dollars they
only gotta pay a b
and lebron so i hear guys talk about
if there was no salary cap the seller
cap work for the other players not the
great players
unless they act like the great players
aren't getting compensated james harden
makes 41 million dollars a year
he's good same thing with katie and
kyrie they both make 40 million a year
but if if we just gonna pay listen
anthony davis lebron
kd steph those guys
to probably deserve to be paid whatever
they can be paid well then we wouldn't
be able to pay anybody
else because you you're not gonna you're
not gonna pay all the other guys
30 40 million dollars you only need
those stars
john wall makes 40 million dollars a
year that's my point dan
[Laughter]
and john wall's a good player john
wall's a good player i don't want to
disparage him he's a good player
but i hate these guys when i get on they
get on tv so
well if we had the free market well we
can pay lebron but
wait okay uh i'm gonna pay lebron
a hundred million everybody else on the
team gonna make a million
uh what's the most you ever made in your
career
five million dollars felt pretty rich
didn't you
you know dan i never hate on these young
guys for making money because i made
more money than
dr j and wilt chamberlain and they were
and bill russell
and they were clearly much much better
players to me
but hey it's a it's a it is what it is
i wish all these guys great success and
i hope they save their money
that's the most important thing but you
can't ever
worry about because because of inflation
every generation well i tell you what's
going to be interesting
when the covet tax become due
because not just in basketball there's
gonna be ramifications in every sport
because the the culvert thing is real
and i think in the next three or four
years
that coveted tax is gonna come due
it it's probably gonna be what you said
earlier they're gonna like
hey you other guys are bombs i'm gonna
pay lebron
i'm gonna pay a d the rest of you guys
gonna take the minimum
and i think not just in basketball
though i think it's gonna happen like
that in every
sport cause these owners they didn't buy
these teams to lose money
happy new year good to see you hey dan
it's good to see you guys man i hope
everybody's safe and healthy
uh this covet thing man it's been crazy
and um you look good you look like you
lost some weight
i'm getting in shape dad i i promise
that's my new year's resolution
uh to get my fat but i'm tired of being
fat it doesn't look good it doesn't feel
good so that's my new year's resolution
what are you waiting for what are you
waiting for
i'm listening i'm tired of wearing all
black clothes
i want to wear some i want to wear some
lighter colors this year
that's my gold i want to go on my other
closets
what do you weigh now uh 3 30.
what's the most you weighed 3 50.
what's shockway
oh he'd be if he get on the scale it's
going to be it's going to say one person
at a time
oh god is he is shaq
as shaq iv spins is what does he weigh
400 oh yeah hell yeah oh my god
hell yeah but you know what the thing
about it
that ain't bad he's just the biggest
human being i've ever been around in my
life
i mean he you you know you've been
around ain't
he's just humongous how did you compete
with that
you're six four and a half or whatever
and and you competed with that man i
many times he was saying that the first
time he saw shaq he was standing beside
robert paris he says
yeah it's about time for us to get out
kell tells that story all the time he
said the first time he saw shaquille in
person he says he was
robbing paris chief it's time for us to
get a look for another profession
because these kids are too big now
but you see steve nash be an mvp
with his size steph curry like that's
what's amazing to us
when we see this and see how big guys
are
fast strong yeah but yeah but listen
i i didn't play against will chamberlain
but
other than shaquille and i guess wilt
chamberlain
those were the only two guys who were
bigger
stronger than everybody else i mean
listen i played against guys who were
seven feet tall
but they didn't have shaquille's
athletic ability
and things like that you know uh mark
eden was a hell of a player
uh you know i'm trying to think of my
tombow
but those guys you that's like night and
day when you talk about athletic ability
mark eden was a hell of a shot blocker
sold in the tombow
but if those guys were to get in a foot
race or a jumping contest with shaq
it would be a no-brainer i mean that guy
that guy was the most
dominating physically imposing guy i've
ever played against and seen in my life
but like i said when you play against
another seven photo like when i played
against mikael who was seven feet
of parish those guys were big but they
had
they didn't have the most amazing
athletic ability
i you know just to see shaq out there i
remember when he was in orlando and he's
like leading the fast break you know he
just
he so desperately wanted to be a point
guard at times and just be out there and
run and
run in the three-on-two break oh dude
i'm telling you to be to be that big and
that fast
is just crazy dan i mean it really was
yeah uh hey it's great to talk to you as
always thanks for joining us and uh we
hope to see you soon
yes sir my brother be safe that's
charles barkley
tnt inside the nba analyst